isn't that surprising that as your
income Rises if you're black you're more
likely to get pulled over by that I mean
it's the idea behind that like oh are
you driving a better car and for a cop
that's a flag likewise you know why
would a black man be driving a newer car
it seems to be that hi I'm Nicolas be
with reason TV and we are at the
international students for liberty
conference 2017 talking to Cato's Emily
ikan she's the director of polling and a
senior research fellow Emily thanks for
talking to us thanks for having me
you've been doing a bunch of stuff that
is fascinating about criminal justice
issues and the ways that different types
of Americans view the police when you
ask people including people of different
groups who may or may not feel they're
being disfavored by cops they agree on
what the police should be doing yeah
what should the police be doing and you
know happen what do you what do you find
that well to reiterate your first point
we often focus a lot of attention on
these big racial gaps and confidence
toward the police you know how well they
do their jobs are they accountable to
these too much force we really emphasize
that a lot but to your point what the
polling data suggests is that people are
actually far more unified when it comes
to what the police should be doing so
for instance we asked people what they
thought the top priority that the police
should be their top three priorities and
across racial groups in partisan groups
it was the same it was fighting violent
crime protecting you from being a victim
of violent crime and fighting property
crime like robbery the drug war was very
low on that list and also very low on
that list with enforcing traffic laws
which I found somewhat amusing was there
anything in that about enforcing
immigration laws or do people think
that's something the police should be
doing that's an excellent question we
didn't look at that in our survey but we
did look at a bunch of other reforms
that criminal justice experts believe to
go a long way in improving police
community relations and what we found
might surprise you is that despite the
big racial gap in perceptions of how the
police actually do their job people
agree on what the police should do but
you're overwhelming majorities of all of
all groups think that the police should
not be allowed to take your property
cash or cars until you've been convicted
of a
driving civil asset forfeiture
overwhelming majorities oppose racial
profiling they believe that independent
agencies should investigate police
misconduct rather than have that be
determined internally which is the case
in most jurisdictions it has been and if
not to say it isn't related to their
behavior but over the past few years
certainly since incidents like Ferguson
Police you know kind of approval ratings
of the police and the in general or in
the aggregate have been going down what
groups have the lowest of you know give
cops the lowest approval ratings so we
find that young people people with lower
incomes living in the cities African
Americans and Hispanics tend to have
lower views of the police what we found
is that if you were to equalize
perceptions of how the police use force
do they use too much force or too little
force and do the police treat everyone
equally under the law
so are they racially biased or nor if
you were to equalize those two things
there would be no racial gap in
attitudes towards and Glee's so those
are the two issues that are really
driving a lot of these disparate
attitudes toward the police so even
though there are age differences there
are differences by whether you live in a
city or a suburb really the the largest
driver of attitudes toward the police
seems to be differences by racial groups
is there I mean is there a reason to
take that perception concretely and say
yeah well you know what actually
Hispanics and blacks do get treated
worse by the by the police so they're
having a rational you know their
disapproval is a rational response to
that so we definitely found evidence in
our research that suggested that people
are having different experiences with
the police now this is controversial
polls show that when you ask people do
you think that these incidents in which
police are using excessive force against
African Americans or Hispanics is that
just an are these isolated incidents or
do they represent a pattern of systemic
behavior Republicans tend to think that
these are just isolated instance you
know the bad apples out there and that
is wrong but it's not indicative of a
systemic problem Democrats came tend to
look at this and they say now this is a
systemic problem in our data we found
evidence that it perhaps
is a systemic problem so I can go
through those yeah first we found that
as african-americans income Rises they
become disproportionately more likely to
be pulled over by the cops so this is
like the Chris Rock effect or senator
Tim Scott Republican from South Carolina
where he said he was pulled over seven
times in one year isn't that surprising
that as your income Rises if you're
black you're more likely to get pulled
over by that I mean it's the idea behind
that like oh are you driving a better
car and for a cop that's a flag likewise
you know why would a black man be
driving a newer car it seems to be that
and that's what senator Scott said he
said the only sometimes he said sure he
was speeding
other times the only thing he was doing
was driving a nice car in the wrong
neighborhood and police thought that
that was suspicious right now when
people start to feel like the cars that
they're driving and if they're driving
in a certain neighborhood and that's
going to somehow make them suspicious
this is obviously unequal treatment of
the law right let's talk a little bit
about Millennials when you work the
reason we did a major millennial poll
you and I wrote some stories together
about that Millennials overwhelmingly
broke for Hillary Clinton as they did
for Barack Obama for all of the
discussion among kind of libertarian
groups that Millennials on Social
Attitudes they're very much like
libertarians they like capitalism or
they like profit they don't see these
things as bad things
why aren't Millennials you know why are
Millennials voting for somebody like
Hillary Clinton in such overwhelming
numbers why aren't they more libertarian
and they're voting well to your point
that there were really two bad options
on the ballot and sure people could vote
third party and in fact we saw it card
quadrupling the third party vote it
might actually ride as we get more
updated data so a lot of people did vote
for third parties but the two parties
have a lot of control over the system
and people feel a tug to vote for one of
the two parties because they want to be
on at least one of the winning team so
when you have two bad options
Millennials look at Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump and Donald Trump is
diametrically opposed to them on most
issues that majorities of them care
about immigration tolerance for of
difference and treating people with
respect is something that's very
important too
and even on those economic issues where
millenials are a little bit more
centrist Donald Trump he's more
suspicious of free trade and we'd like
him to be um he's not particularly you
know libertarian on economic issues at
all so between the two Hillary Clinton
was far more supportive of immigration
global trade than Donald Trump was now
that being said I think that if you look
at the primaries that's where we saw
young people and overwhelming numbers
voting for Bernie Sanders and a lot of
these a lot of the primaries 70 to 80
percent of people under 30 voted for
Bernie Sanders so this was giving me a
heart attack though because Bernie was
the original like you everything you get
should be free and we'll figure out you
know the five or six billionaires in the
world that will pay for it our Bernie
Sanders voters Millennials are they at
all libertarian or are they the are they
the the remnant that is just totally
against it well it's a great question I
had the same reaction first as you did
because Bernie Sanders describes himself
as a Democratic Socialist he wanted
dramatically more government control of
the nation's industries and he said he
doesn't want the government to run
everyone's businesses when it comes to
health care and education he wants a lot
more government control now what we also
saw though is a lot of these young
people what drew them to Bernie Sanders
and a lot of it had to do with style his
authenticity and also when it comes to
civil libertarian issues he's often
better
he was often better than Hillary Clinton
what we go for and what we found in the
data is we have this measure to kind of
get an idea of who really cares about
individual autonomy or not so an example
question might be people should be
allowed to do dangerous and
self-destructive thing as long as they
don't put other people at risk the
people who answered yes to that question
they tended to say they were going to
vote for either Rand Paul Senator Rand
Paul from Kentucky or Bernie Sanders
so we did have some of these look civil
libertarians who didn't really have
strong opinions on economic issues now
what they do see is the rising cost of
tuition in schools they don't know that
that's largely because of government
intervention in
system but they see someone who's
authentic and someone who cares about
civil liberties which also explains Ron
Paul a few years before another old guy
who's not particularly charismatic but
very idealistic and very good on those
issues yes exactly so is if if you're
you know crystal ball gazing for the
2020 election and if you're telling
Democrats or Republicans or libertarians
here here is the message that's going to
you know grab the attention at least at
first of Millennials what would it be
that's a hard question to answer what I
will say is there's a danger right now
and the danger is that Donald Trump has
come to a body many things that
Millennial despise and at the same time
because of some of the people who are
working with him who do believe in free
market reforms and free enterprise that
there's a danger that those two things
can become mix that those anti-immigrant
attitudes you know banning must the
temporary payout of Muslims entering the
u.s. can get merged into the idea of
free markets free enterprise that I
think is that they'd worry for young
people we need to show them that those
things are not connected and that you
can believe in one and not the other all
right well we will leave it there thank
you so much we've been talking with
Emily Eakins at the Cato Institute she
directs their polling operations there
and works as a senior analyst as well
Emily thanks so much thank you for
reason TV I'm Nicolas Lee
[Music]
you
[Music]